[Aplausos]
alvos têm 40 anos uma bela tarde de
outono a assistir televisão
carlos deixa cair uma xícara de café na
sua mão direita em quarto com aquilo
o carro se pega pensando vários dias a
fio porque aquela correria mas não foi
só aquela xícara de café causa da sua
mão
semanas após esse evento carlos começa a
ter um tremor na sua mão direita
o temor que era incessante de noite e
principalmente o repouso
mas não foram só o temor que comandava
carlos no espaço mais algumas semanas
aquilo que era um tremor se transforma
também em uma rede de 10 de realizar os
movimentos então carlos pré é apta para
procurar um médico e ser aquele problema
e se o médico que ele procurou e dá o
diagnóstico de ansiedade mas carlos
ainda continuava com aquilo se
perguntando se de fato há só uma
sociedade que justificavam aqueles
sintomas e no decorrer de mais algumas
semanas
o que era só um tremor uma rigidez no
braço se transforma também não há
rigidez na perna direita
então carlos resolve através de seu
vizinho procurar um médico neurologista
é que carros vai ler o lojista lojista
dá um diagnóstico que para carlos foi
uma forma de sentença
carlos tinha doença de parkinson e se
vocês quantas pessoas
vocês conhecem com doença de parkinson e
com grande pode ser o impacto na
qualidade de vida da pessoa com a doença
hoje sabe se que a doença é a segunda
doença neurodegenerativa mais comum
perdendo somente para o swu zaine uma
pessoa em cada nove acima dos 80 anos
tem doença de parkinson
tendo em vista que a expectativa de vida
da população está aumentando
torna-se bem evidente um grande impacto
na qualidade de vida das pessoas
isso trará mas não era só isso voltando
à história de carros carlos recebeu o
diagnóstico o médico tratou o prescrever
medicações que eram pertinentes
carlos ficou bem durante o processamento
de cinco anos se passaram cinco anos e
devido à complicação tardia da medicação
que é melhor medicação para doença de
parkinson humano provoca caos desenvolve
novamente um ou outro tipo de sintoma
agora ele não tem mais o tremor como
tinha outrora a rigidez é menor porque
os remédios afinal de contas contas ele
via streaming essa rigidez mas agora tem
um outro estudo que é secundário o uso
crônico por um lugar na europa as
chamadas disse messias
é nesse contexto que carros começa a
procurar na internet
a solução do seu problema será que essa
linha final existe mais alguma coisa que
pode ser feita e caso ver na internet
sobre cirurgia de partes e nesse
contexto carlos nos procuram o
consultório carros questiona o doutor
existe cura para a doença de parkinson
com cirurgia
e se eu digo não existe cirurgia de
parkinson vai melhorar alguns sintomas
mas não vai curar a doença a doença
infelizmente a doença incurável crônica
progressiva mas certamente carros os
sintomas melhoraram bastante você vai
ter uma melhor qualidade de vida
certamente a sua vida melhorar com a
cirurgia
esse caso a pergunta mas eu posso morrer
devido à cirurgia e eu digo carlos
chances são bem pequenas ser mais
preciso estatisticamente falando
o ponto 1 por cento mas além disso posso
ter sequelas doutor esse carlos indaga
e eu respondo sim pode ter sequelas mas
há chances também são bem reduzidos
é nesse contexto que carlos é decidir e
optam pela cirurgia
mas como as frases de efeito do mtur
basicamente campos
coloca-se um álbum chamado a vulcaniano
que essa peça metálica e esse material
aqui vai nos dar precisam da cirurgia na
ordem de 1 milímetro que margem de erro
ou seja esse
essa coroa vai nos permitir implantaram
eletrodos no cérebro com mais dinheiro
de menos de 1 milímetro mas quais tipos
de cirurgia existem doutor eu vim falar
sobre marca passo
eu vim falar sobre lesões lesões no
cérebro
sim existem dois tipos de cirurgia caos
o primeiro mais antigo feito desde a
década de 40 chamados cirurgia abla
ativa ou lesão
é uma cirurgia como o próprio nome diz
leva a lesão cerebral uma lesão
controlada mas elas são feitas somente
naquela estrutura que é relacionada à
doença não é feita de forma aleatória
uma lesão no cérebro é de uma forma
divertida não você escolhe um ponto
exato que faz a lesão é uma cirurgia
segura e eficaz e barata resultados
muito bons muito bons efeitos desde a
década de 40 conforme a família e como
efeito do mtur através daquela coroa
implantação eletrodo a ponta desse
eletrodo será responsável por fazer
lesão ou seja em toda a trajetória de
eletrodos no cérebro somente a sua ponta
é que vai vai fazer lesão
o restante do trono provocar a lesão no
seu cérebro apenas passar para o seu
cérebro mas sem fazer lesão mas como é
feita essa lesão do turno não entende
na verdade essa ponta do eletrodo ela
esquenta
xx que você escolhe previamente de
acordo com o tipo de problema do
paciente e esse eletrodo é conectar um
cabo que vai até este aparelho grande
aqui chamado aparelho de radiofreqüência
é esse aparelho de forma controlada e
pelo operador
você liga esquenta temperatura x nesse
caso 80 graus celsius não escolhemos e
nós a conhecemos somente a ponta desse
eletrônico conforme tinha fugido mas o
marcapasso cerebral do turno
eu vim falar sobre macapá cerebral eu
achei muito interessante porque a pessoa
coloca uma capacitou em seguida melhora
bastante seus sintomas
sim existe essa opção é um marca-passo
cerebral o chamado dbs da sigla em
inglês de estimulação cerebral profunda
é a cirurgia mais realizada no mundo
hoje sem sombra de dúvidas
ela é superior a cirurgia do ativa ou a
cirurgia com lesão ao da mesma maneira
como a cirurgia de lesão a técnica é bem
semelhante e também devemos colocar essa
coroa e através dessa coroa o mesmo
mecanismo introduzimos eletrodo e esse
eletrodo fica permanentemente implantado
no cérebro do paciente
diferente da cirurgia curativa onde vai
essa lesão e retira-se eletrônico
nesse caso o eletrodo o marcapasso ele
fica encantado e é conectada a um cabo e
um marcapasso prometido que é implantado
aqui na região do peito do paciente
então esse marcapasso ele gera um
estímulo
esse estímulo passa pelos fios longos
até o eletrodo e esse eletrodo inibe os
sintomas da doença e de que forma
podemos controlar isso
existe então um aparelho uma forma de um
telefone celular antigo que você pode
colocar em cima da pele onde o
marcapasso está implantado e você pode
aumentar ou diminuir a carga do seu
marca-passo acordo com a demanda do
paciente o que você observa no exame
clínico o paciente tem mais rigidez você
aumenta a carga ele tem medo você
diminui a cara
então por isso um método que utiliza
mais hoje em dia você for dar mais
opções terapêuticas culpa
mas voltemos novamente às questões dos
carros e como é feita a cirurgia do tubo
ser anestesia geral não carlos nossa
nesse geral é de fundamental importância
que você esteja acordado durante
cirurgia acordado eu ouvi falar disso em
baga carros muito interessante
isso é uma coisa nova em doutor não é
nova carros por mais que as pessoas
queiram dizer que sim a impressão às
vezes a mídia venda como tal um novo ser
feito desde a década de 40
e pra que eu tenho que estar acordado
autocarros e indaga
na verdade você tem que estar acordado
porque nós teremos que examinar sua
parte motora a sua fala ea sua visão é
fundamental importância sendo um
implante do eletrodo sendo uma lesão
para que melhor resultado seja o motivo
então a gente agora convido vocês
entraram na cirurgia conosco
tá bom não vai ter sangue podem ficar
tranquilos
é basicamente seria isso a gente pode
observar os testes e aquele aparelho que
eu mostrei esse aparelho que está
fazendo a lesão
ok e ao mesmo tempo estamos examinando o
paciente e vendo as funções motoras do
paciente nos certificamos de que de fato
a paciente não tem problema algum
durante o procedimento
além disso existem outros positivos que
dão segurança ao paciente como por
exemplo isso aqui que é chamado de micro
registro o que isso na verdade é um
eletrodo ainda menor do que os 2 no qual
me referi e também e também implantamos
no cérebro e ele nos dará o registro
neurônio prometido ele nos diz em que
frequência amplitude neurônio está
disparando geram descargas isso a gente
extremamente importante porque cada
região do cérebro e tem uma diferença
diferente freqüência amplitude disparo
então você reconhecer por isso aqui com
esse traçado onde eu estou implantar o
metrô daquela região ou fazer minha
lesão naquela região então aqui nós
podemos ver
nós podemos ver o disparo dos neurônios
é um aqui me certifico olha esse traçado
como é diferente dos outros a freqüência
disparo não sei que aqui estão na região
correta mas enfim os sintomas de carros
pioraram e agora ele se decidir pela
cirurgia
tá chegamos no ponto final à esquerda
vemos carros antes da cirurgia à direita
após a cirurgia
esse é um sintoma de carros estavam
agora não tem vida social
ele sequer conseguem suíço a igreja ele
consegue mal consegue um restaurante
sair com os amigos
amanhã são os sintomas da doença mas
aqui está carro depois da cirurgia a que
foi operado óbvio alguns sintomas
persistiram persistiram conforme
tínhamos dito a cirurgia não vai curar a
cirurgia não vai resolver todos os
problemas mas sim melhorar a qualidade
de vida do paciente mas não só isso
existe alguma forma de se quantificar
isso aí e que freqüência esse tremor com
grande ou pequena esse tremor
visualmente nós vimos isso aqui mais uma
vez existe uma forma de parametrizar uma
forma de quantificar esse números
pensando nisso os colegas da
universidade federal de uberlândia na
pessoa que eu sou adriana é desenvolveu
essa luva que têm micro sensores e essa
luva ela consegue pra gente uma vez o
paciente
vestindo a luva ela consegue presente
através de gráficos mostrar em que
frequência thaís tremor e que a
amplitude da stre mor e nos dizer por
exemplo depois de uma cirurgia um
tratamento com o remédio com dengue o
paciente está ou não baseado em números
não só na imagem
isso é uma forma de você e
individualizar o tratamento da paciente
aquilo que você pretende de melhor então
com carlos obteve uma melhora da
qualidade de vida e isso é inegável esse
objetivo final seja cirurgia de lesão o
ablativo o primeiro método mais antigo
seja cirurgia do marcapasso
existe um grande discussão na literatura
o que faremos abraçam o marcapasso
a ablação método antigo mas mais barato
mas é mais rápido
então se aplica muitas condições de cada
paciente isso tem que ter em mente mas o
marcapasso inegavelmente é superior aos
motivos nós mencionamos anteriormente
e nós não podemos que seja todas as
técnicas cirúrgicas alex com tudo na
vida que é que é desenvolvido na ciência
o que nós temos hoje é fruto daquilo que
foi usada no passado nenhuma técnica
surgiu do nada sem um conhecimento
prévio
assim é como nesse exemplo a cirurgia do
marcapasso cerebral ela não começou nada
é feito desde a década de 90
ela começou na verdade a partir das
cirurgias laborativas utilizam e com com
certa convicção que temos lidando com
isso no nosso dia a dia as técnicas
cirúrgicas que virão no futuro
certamente também se basearam nas teclas
que nós usamos hoje ele está aqui que
nós usamos no passado mas o que importa
pra gente é a qualidade de vida do
paciente enquanto o paciente vai
melhorar
se vai ser com cirurgia regional com
marca-passo a gente não importa o que
importa o quanto o paciente vai estar
satisfeito
o controle vai estar melhor dos seus
sintomas o que pode mudar de fato na
vida dele e no caso carlos mudou
isso foi uma carta que ele escreveu ela
tem umas situações pós operatórias
antes da cirurgia e depois da cirurgia a
que ele lista alguns tópicos algumas
coisas obviamente não melhoraram
conforme mencionamos outros melhoraram
bastante como por exemplo não virar de
lado o grupo suíço uma característica
marcante da doença
notem vocês acordar à noite madrugada
não conseguir se virar na cama porque os
movimentos são travados com isso porque
para algumas pessoas podem parecer pouco
isso muda radicalmente a qualidade de
vida da pessoa
outros como por exemplo não fazia barba
ou seja ele não tinha independência
outra pessoa outros o terceiro chique
ele sai pra ele
agora carlos faz a barba sozinho e
carlos foi submetido à cirurgia ablativa
não foi de marcapasso então a mensagem
que fica city é o seguinte nós temos que
abraçar o novo as tecnologias
eu sou extremamente entusiasta uso de
novas tecnologias na medicina e já foram
mais que comprovavam a sessão
muito benéficas e trazem avanços e
muitos benefícios na vida dos pacientes
mas não podemos cair no modismo de achar
que somente o que é novo o que é mais
tecnológico é o como está na moda e
devemos só usar aquilo isso aquilo
funciona então aqui está um exemplo um
paciente foi operado no texas na década
de 1940 então pensemos nisso porque
obviamente as técnicas cirúrgicas estão
evoluindo mas não podemos jamais pensar
que uma técnica que é antiga e por ser
antiga não funciona
podemos sim refletir isso não só na vida
como os orientais muito fazem de
valorizar aquilo que é antigo
a experiência do idoso e nesse caso
trazendo a experiência de cirurgia nós
vemos o tempo e tempo inteiro uma
experiência foram acumulados no passado
certamente serve muito presente no
presente e continuarão a servir
então essa mensagem obrigado a todos